well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan on censored today Harry and
Megan torched what little was left of
their relationship with the royal family
and what little was left frankly of
their own reputations last week was
mostly sycophantic this latest
installment was downright seditious
Prince Harry mauls his own brother he
accuses his father the new king of being
a liar even as a dig in his late great
grandmother the Queen the standing by
and doing nothing
the royal family is directly accused of
destroying two of its own to protect
itself
and I don't know where it all stops all
this
where does it end we got the book and
then we've got the interview circuit and
until it goes on
it's all apparently a dark plot by
Britain and the Royals to smear the poor
defenseless vulnerable sussexes
trickery treachery hypocrisy and if
there's one conclusion to draw from the
final installment of their Netflix
series it's the Prince Harry surely is
now a traitor to the country that he
once served
William and I both saw what happened in
our in our dad's office
and we made an agreement that we would
never let that happen to our office and
to see my brother's office copy the very
same thing that we promised the two of
us would never ever do
that was heartbreaking it was terrifying
to have my brother um Scream and Shout
at me and my father say things that just
simply weren't true and and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of take it all in they're happy
to lie to protect my brother
and yet for three years they were never
willing to tell the truth to protect us
unbelievable this blistering attack not
only on the institution of the monarchy
but also personally against the senior
Royals who represent our country around
the world is in my view Beyond contempt
in their selfish vapid attempts to
rewrite history recasting themselves as
victims these two have sold their souls
and they sold Harry's family down the
river it's unforgivable and it would
leave a bitter taste in the mouths of
millions of people but there are toe
curling moments in this show too moments
that would upset even the strongest of
stomachs
if you
viewers are force-fed simpering clips of
the pair frolicking on Californian
beaches during covid in Tyler Perry's
mansion no less While most people were
locked down many in tiny homes with lots
of children
but they were the real victims not the
thousands of people dying from a new
pandemic virus
they again cry foul of course the
beastly horrible media for pursuing them
and wanting to take their pictures
whilst persistently throughout this new
installment showing their own highly
intrusive pictures of their own children
did they ask permission from those
children to invade their privacy for
money which is of course the very
challenge they make against the media we
also learned that Megan actually thinks
she's done Britain a favor
get on the plane
and it's not the pilot but whoever is
sort of overseeing the crew
and he came
and he knelt next to my seat and he took
his hat off
and I just remember looking at him he
goes
we appreciate everything you did for our
country
and it was the first time that I felt
like someone
saw the sacrifice
not from my own country
for this country it's not mine
sacrifice is that a joke
a sacrifice
who was this guy
who was this cabin Steward does he exist
or was he like the last one you met you
remember the Lion King premiere it told
you what a hero you were we couldn't
find him could we will we find this
cabin Steward who apparently knelt
and took his hat off in respect for this
awesome woman who'd sacrificed so much
for our country that she's actually
caused so much damage to I'd like to
know that person exists or whether it's
just one of the cabin crew doing what
they normally do which is they kind of
crouched down don't they and they take
their hat off if they've got one on and
ask whether you want chicken or beef
that's normally what happens
we also learned that Harry can't begin
to understand why people might prefer
Catherine the Princess of Wales who of
course never complains never explains
and just does her Duty
this is how I was coming for her this is
how it was cover her if you don't see
the difference and understand why it's
being reported that way why then I can't
help you
I can't I'm sorry I just can't I mean
you sound like a blithering lunatic
don't you Harry
I can't help you
really well let me help you there were a
gazillion critical stories about okay
long before your beloved Megan came
along had nothing to do with Kate's skin
color
and the Megan criticism had nothing to
do with her skin color
at all nothing to do with it she just
started doing things along with you
which were rankly hypocritical and in
some cases downright unpleasant and you
both got called out for it and you don't
like being criticized you think if
anyone criticizes you they're
automatically bullies and racists
but they're not in fact one of the
people has been accused of bullying is
Meghan Markle by several of her Pas at
the palace who had to sign ndas so they
couldn't tell the truth I'm sure that
Meghan Markle and Harry who want the
truth to come out
would like those ndas to be lifted and
maybe they should say so publicly so we
can hear from those Pas who I know at
least one of them was regularly reduced
to tears by The Bullying from Meghan
Markle and if Megan doesn't think she
did bully of course she could sue me
because I've said it now so come and sue
me and let's take it to court
all of this leaves a deeply unpleasant
taste
in the mouth doesn't it and again I say
simply where does it end how much damage
do they want to cause
they can't be allowed back to any Royal
events because they'll probably be wired
up and tight for the next series of
their thrilling life story so what do
they do
what does King Charles do about his own
son
does he cut him off does he strip him on
his titles this is his son
it's a Shakespearean tragedy unfurling
and I'm afraid when it comes to help I
think Prince Harry might be Beyond it
he's been manipulated
and I think partly he's down to him as
well into believing their genuine
Freedom Fighters
to see this institutional gaslighting
that happens
is there is extraordinary
um and that's why everything that's
happened to us
was always going to happen to us because
if you speak truth to power that's how
they respond
truth to power what are you talking
about
your Prince Harry the Duke of Sussex
once third in line to the throne it
doesn't get a lot more powerful than you
before you decant for your freedom
before you gave up any Royal Duty
but wanted to have your Royal cake and
eat it by keeping your title so you
could exploit them and make gazillions
of dollars in America to the highest
bidder and what do you do for that money
you trash your family endlessly and
you're gonna keep doing it as does your
wife who trashes her own family most of
whom she's disowned
is this what happiness looks like Harry
really
you're happy
hating your entire family your wife
hating all hers apart from her mother
like many of the claims in the series
none of this Stacks up does it
were the claims of racism at the palace
but no evidence of who that person was
or what they actually said
apparently Megan she repeated this in
this new installment
was banned by somebody at the palace
from seeking help for her Suicidal
Thoughts think about that for a moment
who was that person are we still working
at the palace does that person exist
did somebody actually say to her you
might be feeling suicidal but it's bad
for the brand you can't get help and if
they did where was her husband in all
this where was Prince Harry Mr mental
health he never stops banging on about
it and about the need to get help and
yet when his own wife apparently had
Suicidal Thoughts he didn't get a help
does that make any sense does that sound
even remotely plausible to you
because it doesn't to me
so that's where we are another tissue of
self-serving lies mostly I suspect we
don't know yet but most of it looks like
the Oprah interview just another load of
unsubstantiated smears designed to
portray them as victims it doesn't
really pass the muster of fact checking
one minute that a beloved young couple
inspired a nation the next nation is
horribly racist out to throw Megan to
the walls in the very beginning the
attacks on the Press were so wicked that
she was hated and feared for her life
but also the entire plot against him was
because there were simply too popular
so they were hated and despised and too
popular and this was all apparently a
heroic fight for family privacy but we
have to learn about that fight in a
hundred million dollar reality TV show
The flaunts a young family and both
about the very public social justice
campaigns Harry and Megan take their
audience for fools they blame everybody
but themselves they present even the
most incendiary of planes with no
evidence and sadly the impact
is real the royal family is getting
damaged the monarchy is getting
tarnished people are believing including
Beyonce it appeared from this series
they're believing that the royal family
are a bunch of callous racists well
they're not I know the royal family a
lot of them well and they're not callous
races and they're Furious about this and
their right to be furious